[Music]
well one in four parents fought with
their kids about money this past month
no surprise as credit card debt is at a
20-year high 60 percent of parents with
children 18 and under have let their
kids borrow their cards to make
purchases and nearly half regret it so
we're sharing ways to teach your kids
some good money habits
with so few schools teaching financial
literacy it falls on us parents to teach
our kids about money there are an array
of money apps to help green light
current go henry fam zoo as well as busy
kid ceo greg merced launched it in 2020.
i'm a certified financial planner i've
got six kids you stick those things in a
blender and this is the kind of thing
you get an app that helps kids learn how
to work and earn money and once you get
that money manage it properly so you can
get ahead in life
tech help convenient for parents as well
as kids piggy banks and envelopes just a
thing of the past gone are the days
where like you're gonna pay i want you
to mow the lawn and i'm gonna give you
seven dollars or eight dollars and you
have cash in your pocket in the right
denominations like that doesn't happen
anymore
with most of these apps the parent opens
the account adds funds from their bank
securely orders cards for their kids
assigns chores and other ways to earn
money the busy kid app automatically
splits up the money placing 50 percent
into savings and the remainder in
spending and sharing categories merced
says it teaches your kids a balanced
financial approach and boy did it pay
off in his household i've been trying to
teach my kids this stuff for a very long
time busy kids kind of at the tail end
of this but
all
six of five of the six have kind of
almost left the nest and all of them all
five of those have had more than ten
thousand dollars saved up before they
left the net
i think that's a lot of money okay i
think that's fantastic
that is a lot of money well use daily
opportunities to teach your kids have
them watch the dollar signs when you gas
up your car talk to them about how long
it took you to earn that money when
you're out to eat have them help you
calculate the tip and see how much it
costs to go out to a restaurant